dai ragazzi sono uno scrittore sulle
cose cli ge
buonissima visione a tutti quanti aj ben
come fai ad avere la iena gelidi fianco
e pensare che non sia un copyright mio
va bene ahia ahia
l'ho tolto la pausa lo stop loss a noi
con loro ho tolto il nuovo tentato
divampare prima niente con 9 gol
gravissimo se vi riporto come vuoi
bravo tocca bracali mamma mio papà che
gol stranissimo l'ho mai fatto un gol
così america non si capiva niente di
quello che stava succedendo ben fatto e
chi un avanzato 26 persone poi book
va beh sai settimana magari vado io
attendo li ha passato in mezzo
ok non mandai non male non male come la
parte non lo so però una male e va bene
ma già il cavolo era in parte fa visse
in serata la buona d'anticipo perché non
posso toccare la palla in limba di
palidoro nota arrivati arrivato arrivato
riva mamma mia
no ho ritirato ci sia qualcuno che rompe
le scatole 4 niente non si può giocare
colori invece è poi i covi che si libra
tutti mamma mia questa è la partita più
bella che abbia mai tanto si si non ha
senso cosa che ho fatto l'elastico
c'erano assenso va bene ma io ma arriva
poi c'è la palla che rimane lì amico mio
tutto questo bel mobile lancio nel
movimento non lo vedo
e vabbè non l'ha colta di un millimetro
deve essere portato invece no no ma lo
toccava attenzione che fa libero è
l'altro occhio
e vabbè ma che sfiga almeno non è
granché e meno bello quando tocco così
genere col nobel autogol
non ci credo non credo a quello che ho
visto giuro che non so come giochi e
morto bellissima cosa leggere com'è
possibile addio non l'ho toccata
forse se lo toccavo era meglio che
poteva entrare però è però detto quindi
voglio rovinare un tiro
pensiamo ok la carta abbastanza vai amy
avanzato mannaia però forse chi non lo
stesso però sono in mezzo e nole va
meglio adesso che prima alle volte
sbagliare un gol
raramente serve perché poi lo fai subito
dopo è quindi portò gli ancora tempo per
arrivarci anno arrivata è andata a
privato perfetto vittoria sia fortissimi
levante trema esempio propriamente tra
sempre sono francesi sono francesi non
si perde dei francesi su roche click non
si beh sono morto bruschi che le burger
come si può prender le vele mannaggia il
ciò che guarda la paz
vabbè ha fatto ha fatto una roba
interessante mi è rimasto dall'alto per
ucciderti lui e non sai cos'è stiamo
giocando nata a world of tanks l'altro
degli workshop ix secolo liste io vi
anticipo entrambi le mie frega nulla
nella mia vita ma perché giusto input
l'auto gol fatto un migliore morte
lascia la prima nelle ragazze orribili
come no goal come l'ha fatto ma quello
che ho segnato poi quest'anno c'è in
giro veramente incredibile e il tocco
pazze guerra come cacchio assegnato poi
ma cos'è ma scherzo è già bellissimo non
ci arriverò mai però infatti cena verso
ma da chianciano pazzesco drammatica
ogni tanto
turba via sempre bellissimo quello è
balzata esattamente come interessava lui
non si sa come il mezzo
io non ho turbo bello vado va bene vado
io marchetto va bene parlano proprio
paolo ho detto vabbè lasciamo ogni
questa insegnanti diesse dei francesi si
sia detto va bene possiamo perdere
perché le funzioni non può perdere sul
canale ordiva vigenti quello dicono i
francesi maggio 2009 secondi e fattivi
di souda e facendo giustamente più forti
di noi
sì sì per averne interessa attenzione ci
vado a portali per poi passarlo
non riesco ha spazzato aperto dell'input
laks local prova scorso che ne ho creato
dal suo come potevo dito pure mamma mia
tra due per libro però erano belli com'è
possibile che abbiamo fatto staccare
impossibile con loro è partito detto ah
beh no niente ok perfetto 2 o 3 va bene
non si sa come mao che intendiamo la
tengo lì ti prego posso controllare così
me ne vado solamente se nei giri
mongrosso i francesi me ne vado no
sapevo troppo tardi ok no che non lo
toccava occhio ma nasce a lui ma ora che
si stava anche segnando da solo peccato
[Musica]
quello arriva ovunque quale superman
abbiamo 13 secondi va in attacco come
faccio così bell'inizio mai
poi qualcosa loreti freddo
ma erano fermi di questi vogliono fare i
figli perché pensano gli dicevano
supplementare pensa se vinciamo noi
pensa se vinciamo noi
oddio sta sfiancando pensa se vinciamo
noi aspetta incredibile va non succede
mai
ma se succede eccolo ripari ma sto
prendendo occhio non ci credo non ci
credo
guarda che mi ha insegnato guarda guarda
guarda è che di fronte al posto di
criminali sulla meritarlo ora tutta
mandamento giusto così è giusto
va bene i ragazzi l'episodio di rock
etnica è finito chissà che l'ultimo che
esce con questo sito perché fa adesso
torno in my casa nuova sono anche tutto
arancione che bello ci pervenisse che
sul ragazzo così dice vi piace anche di
socializzazione
[Musica]